[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24 en
el año 2021 se presentaron en colombia
cerca de 44 mil denuncias asociadas a
delitos sexuales
61% de ellas corresponden a casos o
contra niños niñas y adolescentes eso
sin contar un subregistro escandaloso e
indignante ya que se estima que sólo 13%
de los delitos sexuales reportados y a
nivel nacional son llevados ante un juez
en este programa vamos a analizar el
porqué la violencia sexual es una más de
tantas enfermedades del machismo y de
las masculinidades de tóxicas pero antes
de veamos los datos
1993 denuncias asociadas a delitos
sexuales reportó la fiscalía colombiana
en el año 2021 seis de cada diez casos
son abusos a menores de edad los datos
fueron recogidos y analizados por el
laboratorio de economía de la educación
de la universidad javeriana los efectos
de estos abusos en los niños niñas y
adolescentes tienden a ser permanentes y
agravarse en el tiempo sus vidas cambian
para siempre y el llegar a la data
adulta los menores abusados tienen una
probabilidad dos veces mayor de caer en
pobreza o de tener dificultades
económicas sin mencionar las
consecuencias emocionales y en su salud
mental tienen tendencia al consumo de
alcohol o de drogas aumentan en la
probabilidad de tener conductas
delictivas y de relaciones familiares
conflictivas muy frecuentemente los
agresores son personas cercanas a los
pequeños principalmente en contextos
familiares o escolares la tarea de
educación por los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos y por la protección de la
niñez
corta y mientras tanto niñas niños y
niñas son víctimas con secuelas que
pasan por retrasos en el desarrollo
episodios de ansiedad estigmatización y
dificultades para relacionarse y tener
una vida digna y feliz
vamos a hacer lo posible por analizar el
tema y para ello nos acompañan dos
invitadas en ellas hoy son paola andrea
lópez directora de la fundación de red
por la prevención contra el abuso sexual
infantil y christina arrocero asesoras
legales del centro de derechos
reproductivos gracias a ambas por estar
con nosotros y nos basamos en este
estudio que realizó la universidad
javeriana de colombia para empezar a
revisar cuál es la situación de la
infancia en cuanto a las denuncias de
abusos sexuales paola quiero comenzar
con usted preguntándole cómo se protege
un niño del abuso sexual
buenos dias angela muchas gracias por la
invitación carmen muy buenos días
gracias por este espacio hay que aclarar
primero y es muy importante que los
responsables de la protección de los
niños somos dos adultos no podemos dejar
esta responsabilidad al cien por ciento
a los niños podemos enseñar pautas de
autocuidado de protección de si estás en
este riesgo si tienes temor si alguien
te hace este ofrecimiento corre avisa
llámame hay unas alertas podemos
enseñarle a los niños pero el
responsable número uno de la protección
de ellos somos los adultos bien y
continuando entonces en esa línea y
viendo esa responsabilidad que tenemos
pues hagamos la tarea de educar cuáles
son los signos de alerta como prevenimos
que esto suceda
bueno hay dos temas que acaba de abordar
uno temas de prevención dices cómo
prevenimos empecemos a hablar de nuestro
cuerpo y aclarar que el niño como sujeto
de derechos es dueño de su cuerpo y
también tiene la posibilidad de aprender
todas las partes de su cuerpo denominar
abiertamente los genitales hablar con
tranquilidad respeto frente a lo que
significa el pecho la cola el pene vulva
la vagina al llamar las cosas por su
nombre y hablar con claridad y valores y
respeto acerca del cuerpo este es el
paso número uno en términos de
prevención y con respecto a lo que
mencionas a cómo detectar los casos hay
que estar alertas a cambios emocionales
y comportamentales de los niños es
indispensable que cada papá mamá o
cuidador esté pendiente cuando hay
cambios importantes en las emociones en
el desarrollo escolar en el
comportamiento social de los niños es
importante acercarnos y empezar a
averiguar qué es lo que está originando
estos cambios importantes como por
ejemplo de la pasividad a la agresividad
a un excelente desarrollo escolar o de
un desarrollo promedio e inferior a eso
cambios en la agresividad hay que
empezar a detectarlos y evaluarlos y por
supuesto comportamientos
hipersexualizados masturbación excesiva
comentarios acerca del cuerpo de la
sexualidad de la genitalidad que
previamente no había tenido en un
contexto ni escolar ni en familia hay
que verificar qué está pasando con esos
comportamientos y christina porque nos
quedamos tan cortos en educación es
sexual y en derechos reproductivos y
también en derechos sexuales desde el
estado hasta la casa porque estamos tan
cortos y le va a poner un ejemplo-
castizo
no hace mucho yo no sabía la diferencia
entre una vulva y una vagina desde ahí
nos estamos bajando
sí sin duda y muchísimas gracias por
esta invitación para hablar de este tema
tan importante y es que en realidad
existen una serie de obstáculos y
barreras para el acceso efectivo a la
educación sexual integral que han hecho
cada vez más difícil que en las escuelas
colegios y en otros espacios las
personas puedan recibir información
completa sobre su sexualidad sobre su
reproducción y sobre la forma adecuada
de relacionarnos entre las personas y
recientemente un caso que llevamos desde
el centro de derechos reproductivos que
es el caso paola guzmán albarracín ante
la corte interamericana reconoció que la
educación sexual integral es una parte
muy importante del derecho a la salud y
del derecho a la educación y que es muy
importante que los niños niñas y
adolescentes puedan recibir este tipo de
información adecuada a su capacidad
evolutiva con el fin de que tal como lo
mencionaba paola puedan identificar las
partes de su cuerpo puedan comprender
cuáles son los límites frente a ese
cuerpo y de qué manera ellos pueden
también alertar o identificar una
situación de abuso como éstas sin duda
es un reto grandísimo no sólo en
colombia sino en toda la región dado que
existen poca implementación de las
normas que establecen estos
reconocimientos frente a la educación
sexual integral y también algunas
barreras culturales que tienden a
mirarla el acceso a la educación sexual
integral como algo malo cuando en
realidad es una herramienta muy
importante tanto de prevención como de
transformación de estos idearios que
permiten y facilitan la violencia sexual
contra niñas y adolescentes y hablemos
de las raíces de este problema yo creo
que se habla desde hace tantos años y en
tantos espacios pero todavía no somos
capaces de enfrentar la dificultad que
viene desde una población empobrecida
sin acceso a la educación y sin acceso a
oportunidades familias que no hacen lo
necesario sino lo que pueden con lo poco
que tienen y que son muy frecuentemente
porque son los más vulnerables muy
frecuentemente las principales víctimas
de la violencia y del abuso sexual
correcto es una práctica que está
tristemente más normalizada de lo que
uno podría imaginarse es una realidad
que se presenta muy diariamente en los
países por ejemplo en latinoamérica es
de hecho la única región del mundo donde
las niñas menores de 14 años que
resultan embarazadas de violencia sexual
están en incremento el número de estos
casos se ha venido incrementando el
contrario lo que ha ocurrido en otras
regiones del mundo esto también tiene
una relación con el hecho de que las
niñas no tienen suficiente protección
dentro de sus entornos que deberían ser
seguros y en muchos casos estamos
hablando de agresores que son cercanos
dentro de su familia o personas que
están dentro de su círculo social lo que
hace también crea una serie de
dificultades para la presentación de
denuncias sumado nuevamente a la falta
de educación sexual integral que hace
difícil que estos casos se puedan
visibilizar y como ya se mencionaba al
inicio en las cifras el subregistro en
estos casos es muy importante entonces
cuando vemos este panorama de manera
global es claro que todavía existen unos
retos muy grandes para poder responder a
las necesidades de las niñas
adolescentes
a una respuesta verdaderamente efectiva
para prevenir y evitar estos casos y
además para que quienes han sufrido este
tipo de violencias tengan una atención
integral en salud como necesita viene
paola además de la normalización porque
es así es normal que a la niña la toquen
le hagan la cojan aún siendo mujeres
adultas nos pasa todos los días el acoso
es una realidad en la calle en todos
nuestros entornos el rango de abuso y de
maltrato infantil es muy amplio entonces
va desde toqueteos a los niños desde
edades que son indecibles hasta por
ejemplo sin fenómenos como el del
embarazo infantil o el embarazo
adolescente
lamentablemente es muy amplio el tema
pero como es en sus términos que debe
hacerse la contención para una niña para
un niño que fue abusado
quiero hacer hay dos precisiones
importantes si tú dices el tema muy
amplio y podríamos hablar muchas horas
acerca de reflexión del tema bien no
mencionan los comportamientos que
consideramos abusivos van y arranca con
comportamiento con comentarios
inapropiados acerca del cuerpo y la
sexualidad del otro porque el no debo de
ninguna manera hacer comentarios a la
otra persona que resulten vulnerando de
alguna manera sus derechos pasan por una
serie de comportamientos físicos pero
también ahora en la virtualidad implica
que a través de los entornos digitales
se están replicando sus comportamientos
sexuales inapropiados que están en
contra de la otra persona y también se
están dando en estos entornos digitales
muchas formas de abuso sexual en menores
de edad
y eso es algo que quiero poner sobre la
mesa sólo para recordarle a toda la
sociedad que no basta con con la
penetración porque hay quienes
consideran que el abuso sexual sólo se
da con la penetración y cuando hablamos
de abuso de abusos son muchas las
maneras de género en que se genera este
delito es muy importante entonces
también que tú lo mencionas hace unos
instantes poder hablar de estas cifras
de cómo contener lo primero hay que
creerle a los niños porque dudamos
muchas veces y pensamos en que tal vez a
la mujer se vistió de determinada manera
o si era una adolescente ella se lo
buscaba pues estaba coqueteando claro no
puede eventualmente estar en un
escenario de conquista pero si mi
respuesta fue no y no me interesa tener
nada más con una persona y no debe ser
respetado porque yo tengo un
consentimiento y socialmente muchas
veces no lo vemos así lo primero es
creerle a nuestros niños ya nuestras
niñas que si alguien me hizo un
comentario
se acercó me está haciendo una caricia o
me o me está mostrando alguna
información de contenido sexual me está
mostrando pornografía y eso a mí no me
gusta yo debo creerle al niño en línea y
adolescente y acompañarlo en sus
emociones
y activar todas las rutas de denuncia ya
todo el acceso a justicia ya salud que
sea necesario para restablecer los
derechos del niño niña y adolescente
pues muchísimas gracias a usted y
terminó con christina la última pregunta
ya nos quedan muy pocos segundos menos
de un minuto christina le hago la
pregunta con la que abría el programa
como todo esto es una muestra de
masculinidades tóxicas de machismo una
consecuencia de una sociedad que no es
igualitaria y que no es respetuosa sí
sin duda es un resultado de una
condición estructural en la que se
discrimina a las niñas mujeres y
adolescentes en todo el mundo pero
particularmente en nuestra región y que
resulta del hecho de dejar de reconocer
la autonomía y dignidad de las niñas y
adolescentes de modo que no importa su
consentimiento de modo que se normalizan
las conductas de violencia contra ellas
bien lo han reconocido comités de
derechos humanos en todo el mundo y la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos estas formas de violencia sin
duda resultan como la consecuencia de
una serie de discriminaciones que las
mujeres niños y adolescentes vivimos en
diariamente por ese salario de un
salario precisamente que los estados
tomen medidas para corregir esta
situación
bueno y para eso estamos aquí nosotros
para denunciar gracias a ustedes y a
nuestros televidentes por estar en ellas
hoy y sigan en france 24
[Música]